scammer vers scammer showdowns are here
and they're using my investigations to
try to Hype their fight all right then I
guess I'm going to use their fight to
Hype their crimes or at least what
should be crimes let's break this down
yo you don't read contracts huh no no
that's people do that for me buddy got
CAU for scamming where were those people
when you got caught for scamming I
didn't scam nobody you oh yeah you
literally signed a contract that said I
am agreeing to scamming my audience you
pay your fans back scaming your fans
back Dylan the difference between you
and I I'm rectifying my situation and I
didn't scam anyone I never made a single
token dollar I never token n bro bought
that priv people I'm rectifying my
situation actively you scammed youring
audience on 20 separate occasions occas
Community notes checked your ass bro
quote unquote Dylan danis has also
scammed his audience on sever I Rao you
every single time I tweet you all right
this clip is amazing it's like Christmas
came early for me and Santa got me
something I didn't even know I wanted
you know these two conmen are out here
trying to decide which of them is the
bigger piece of garbage but not just
that which already brings a smile to my
face but to do it they have to site my
research into the other person while
also denying my research into their own
scams I couldn't have dreamed of a
better scenario they have to have this
throne in their face in what should be a
big moment for them you know they're
have this big fight it's all exciting
and then they get reminded hey you're
actually a scammer like Logan might have
artist in his Twitter bio but I love to
remind him that the real kind of artist
he is is a con artist and the funny
thing is the best they can hope for in
this scenario is just to make the other
guy look worse like nobody looks good
here they just have to say like well
uh-uh I I didn't scam as bad as you did
like for instance Logan literally brings
up my website scammed by Dylan danis
where I show 20 crypto project projects
Dylan promoted for money that are in the
toilet now and Dylan's only response to
that is not that he didn't do it his
response has to be hey that same guy who
caught me also caught you scamming with
kryptoz zo and then Logan has to pretend
with this fake smile he plastered on the
whole time like oh I'm rectifying it bro
which of course he's not he hasn't paid
anyone so this whole thing has been it's
been very special for me to watch uh to
watch my evidence get thrown in their
face by another guy who also got caught
but as funny as that moment was for me I
didn't want to just leave it there at
this level of drama because right now
that's what this is to them it's drama
to use to Hype a fight which scumbag
will get knocked out pay to find out but
I think that's the wrong place to leave
it because people are just going to get
carried away with this rivalry thing
like oh I hate Logan Moore so I got to
support Dylan or vice versa you know
I've seen a lot of that they think just
because Dylan danis is dunking on the
guy they don't like Logan ball that he's
super cool now or they think Dylan's
gone too far with Logan's fiance so I
support Logan now if you think either of
those things you're being conned I mean
that's the grift why do you think they
got the two most unlikable people on the
planet to fight they want to make you
pick aside when the truth is they're
just both terrible and so in the spirit
of talking about their scams since they
brought it up I wanted to remind people
about that what they're really about
Dylan danis as we said promoted 20
crypto scam projects for money but the
funny thing is I don't know if I
emphasized a lot uh we stopped looking
after 20 I mean trying to find the total
number was like counting raindrops and
here's more scams that we missed just to
prove my point and more and more and
more and more and then on the other side
of the table you have Logan Paul who
tries to pretend cryptozoo was his only
scam and he never profited from these
scams but that's not true take dink
doink he pumped and dumped that Meme
coin and made money here's him buying it
uh then he promoted it and then he sold
it he also hyped up Elon gate and then
dumped that coin it's all good Elon gate
made me Rich Elon gate baby let's go
Elon gate token here he is pumping and
dumping another coin called f Elon made
about 100K with that tweet so this guy
is not some one-time scammer or somebody
who got mixed up with a bad person he is
the bad person and there's even stuff I
have in my files which I guess I'll just
drop here even though it probably should
be a whole separate series or video I'm
just so bored with this grifter that I
can't be bothered you know it's just
after you document the you know fifth or
sixth thing it's kind of hard to get
excited about it but I'll put it here
did you guys ever hear of when he
promoted this crypto coin called Omi Omi
I think is like another one bro
bro am I good what are you saying you
you have the same weird little coins
that no one's ever heard of yeah as me
you you have om me yeah bro shut the up
shut up dude no way this totally isn't
planned at all to pump this coin so we
can make money on our young audience now
I know you might want to give him the
benefit of the doubt there but that
reaction was so fake that even their
co-host Mike who's Logan's Whipping Boy
can't help but be skeptical that this
was all a little too rehearsed but I
want a bunch of that cuz I like that
Pokemon definitely y definitely talk
about no on my kids on my kids we've
never talked about this what a Charming
guy well what if I told you I had video
evidence of them talking about buying
Omi colluding behind the scenes before
their podcast went live to you guys yo
Ben we need some more of the these aies
please bro please EOD if possible yep
cuz we have an episode going tomorrow
where we talk very highly of Omi and I
wouldn't be surprised if that cost some
ch AC let's go owe me a wagon let's go
Logan Paul hanging out with the guy he's
never talked about Omi with before
remember on my kids's life and they say
hey we need to buy more of these akomi
or Omi you know more as in they've
bought it before meaning they've talked
about it you know and the guy they're
talking to by the way is Ben godenzi who
is selling these coins to influencers
privately at a discount behind the
scenes and then those people a lot of
them would just dump it off on the
market and hurt retail and worst of all
like they mention the fact they know
it's going on the podcast and that's the
reason they want to buy it early because
they know quote I wouldn't be surprised
if that caught some traction it's just
blatant Market manipulation but you know
some people might say hey don't be so
critical he did say not Financial advice
Omi this is not Financial advice you
know you know Omi is at right now right
it's like fractions it's hundreds of a
penny
003 this is this they didn't pay me to
do this they should I'll reach out to
them but we'll take fre coins see he
said not Financial advice and that he
wasn't paid for this although he said he
was going to try to get paid for this
does that make it a get out of jail free
card well let's look at the impact
obviously insiders like Logan and Chase
got in early and bought it up realizing
that it probably was going to catch some
traction when they came out on this coin
totally uh normally and not in a planned
way in fact one guy sent in
$852,000 right before the podcast saying
we'll be on YouTube and I'll be pushing
it hard on my socials as well Logan then
posts the episode with a cash Emoji
saying broke to millionaire in 14 days
watch or bankruptcy you know more not
Financial advice and what happened next
I think anyone could have predicted this
is the price chart of Omi the dot on the
left is where they told you to buy the
miserable line down is where we are now
Omi is down
99% meaning if you put in a dollar it
would currently be worth less than a
penny so yeah I could go on all day with
these pump and dumps these scams these
promotions that were paid and not
disclosed but the point is with all this
stuff while it is amusing to watch these
scammers call each other scammers this
isn't drama in most societies it would
be considered I don't know like a crime
but you know for some reason the crypto
has the justice department confused so I
don't know what's going to happen but
Logan and Dylan have a very long history
of scamming fans so I'm not on either of
their sides I hope they faed Justice For
What they've done and I hope I've
hijacked a bit of the conversation a bit
of the hype from their dumb fight to
shine a light on their many many
scams
[Music]
time